All right. Well, I'm about to begin, but
it's been 2 days and I'm going to tell
you why it's been 2 days.
All right?
Because I've been busy with my daughters
cuz they're priority now until they
leave April 5th, but also I've been busy
writing a lot of posts. A lot of posts.
But here's what I need to mention before
we begin.
I had shared it. Where is it, man? Where
the hell I shared it on?
I guess I didn't share it here. Hold on,
let me see.
Guess what happened? I think it's on my
Facebook.
Here it is. Guess what happened, folks?
Guess what happened?
Guess what Israel did?
Oh, yeah, but remember they're
anti-Semitic,
anti-Zionist,
they're harboring Hamas terrorists, and
therefore I'm a meanie and David was now
going to do a 20-hour session defending
his lord and master cuz he's Netanyahu's
dog cuz he's scum. You're scum, David.
The Lord rebuke you.
Joint press release. Latin Patriarchate
of Jerusalem
and the Custody of the Holy Land
released March 29, 2026.
Sorry, Rumble. I'm going to get into it,
but these are things we need to address.
Okay?
And you thought the Crusades were was a
bad thing. Really?
You compromised sellouts.
See what they did?
Guess what your beloved Israel
did?
This morning the Israeli police
prevented the Latin Patriarch of
Jerusalem, His Beatitude Cardinal Pier
Battista Pizzaballa. Why does he have
pizza in his name? Head of the Catholic
Church in the Holy Land together with
the Custos of the Holy Land, the Most
Reverend Father Francesco Elpo
OFM, official guardian of the Church of
the Holy Sepulchre from entering the
Church of the Holy Sepulchre
in Jerusalem. Wasn't that one of the
reasons why the Crusades were convened?
Cuz the Muslims were preventing
Christians from going to their holy
sites.
And you still want to be Christian
Zionist, huh?
And you're still going to demonize us?
And you're still going to say that we
are anti-Semitic, anti-Jewish,
we hate Jews,
when they're now showing you their true
colors?
Okay?
The incident Listen, this is a grave
precedent. And this disregards the
sensibilities of billions people around
the world. Yeah, why? When you got Trump
who's sitting now who's prostitute
fighting his proxy war, sending your
sons to be killed with the fake piety
that they want to liberate Iranians.
They don't want to liberate Iranians,
they don't give a damn. Cuz if they
wanted to liberate Iranians, why then
persecute Christians in the Holy Land?
It's all about money and resources.
Right?
Now watch what happens. Look what they
do to them.
The two were stripped stopped en route
while proceeding privately without any
characteristics of procession ceremony
act and were compelled to turn back. As
a result, and for the first time in
centuries, right?
The heads of the church, all right,
who were prevented from celebrating on
look what day, Palm Sunday mass. You see
a spit in the face of you Christians
at the Holy Sepulchre. Palm Sunday, huh?
Cuz they're dogs, they're bastards
Satan. If you still respect David Wood,
that pig, that cult leader, the Muhammad
Ali of Christianity, you guys are jokes.
I will be his enemy until he repents,
and there's not a damn thing you can do
about it, David. You're too biblically
illiterate and stupid. Try to defame me
again and see how far that goes.
Okay?
This incident is a great precedent in
disregard sensibility of billions of
people, spitting in the face of you
Christians
around [clears throat] the world who
during this week look to Jerusalem.
The heads of the churches have acted
with full responsibility and since the
outset of the war have complied with all
imposed restrictions.
Public gatherings were canceled.
Attendance was prohibited, and
arrangements were made to broadcast
the celebrations to hundreds of millions
of faithful worldwide who during these
days of Easter turn their eyes to
Jerusalem
to church of the Holy Sepulchre. Stopped
it.
Why should they not be that emboldened?
Why should they not be that emboldened
when you Americans
give them $360 billion a year, and when
Netanyahu tells Trump to jump, he'll say
how high and fights his wars?
They're spitting in your face, dude.
They're spitting in your face.
Do you blame me for being this way son
of Israel and everyone else?
That I want to be as balanced and honest
and biblical as possible and then
balance out what these bastards, dogs
are doing in the name of Christ, which
is not biblical?
Yep, I'll do it be upon all of them.
Right?
You blame me?
Can you point out one of these Christian
apologists
that are holding these clowns, these
dogs of Setnyahu Akhanab all
and defending your Christian brothers
and sisters?
Can you point to any of them that's part
of his cult movement?
No.
I am no Paul. I'm not good enough to
lick a sandal, but if you love me, can
you pray the same Holy Spirit that fills
Paul fills me to be holy
and pure cuz I struggle.
I say to our lady, it's a struggle for
me, my flesh. May the Lord save her from
my flesh.
I don't pretend to be something I'm not
and I ask God for pity that he forgive
me.
Lord, have mercy on me. Lord, help me
with these issues.
Do you guys blame me for getting angry?
Point one of these Christian apologists
that are calling out these atrocities.
Can you name them for me?
Because they would a channel, Apostle
Prophet Channel, for the last few years
has been nothing about Zionist
propaganda attacking Candace
Tucker, anyone who dares talks talk
about their beloved Lord and savior
Setnyahu.
So, if they're going to make it
political, why not then be balanced?
All right.
So, there goes your celebration
in the Holy Land. Christians are
spitting in your faces.
They're going to stream it live from the
Holy Sepulchre honoring our Lord's
entrance into Jerusalem canceled.
So, that means no
Easter celebration next week
in Jerusalem, in the Holy Sepulchre.
It didn't work. It only worked for their
cult followers.
So, there you go, Rumble, Assyrian
Knight,
Exter Crispy, Disciple Plus, Madingen,
and the beginning, serve the Lord Jesus
Christ when I see you all.
Anyway, let's say the Lord's prayer so
we can begin.
All right.
Let's begin. Name of the Father, and of
the Son, and of the Holy Spirit.
Our Father who art in heaven, hallowed
be thy name. Thy kingdom come, thy will
be done on earth as it is in heaven.
Give us this day our daily bread,
and forgive us our trespasses as we
forgive those
who trespass against us.
And lead us not into temptation, but
deliver us from evil.
For thine is the kingdom, and the power,
and the glory, but now and forever
unto ages of ages, in the name of the
Father, and of the Son, and of the Holy
Spirit. In Jesus' name we pray. Now,
with that said,
the spirit be our teacher.
I've been busy. I've been writing a lot
of posts cuz I'll be doing another
series as well
on what rabbinic sources teach about
the death of the righteous atoning for
the sins of the world.
The merits of the righteous saving the
world. Here it is on both my website and
in the blog.
I've been a busy boy.
Right there.
Here you go.
The high priest atoning death and how
rabbinic Judaism, their traditions,
confirm the New Testament and that Jesus
is our Lord and Savior
cuz God has a sense of humor. He takes
what they say, twists it against them to
silence their slander.
Judaism agrees, the righteous save the
world.
Origin
and the worship well, that's old ones.
Forget these. Sorry. Okay.
The atoning blood of Isaac, new series
about to be set forth. If you pray for
my health, holiness, purity, provision.
>> [snorts]
>> If I go to the Coptic monastery, Egypt,
I won't be back. You think I can land in
Muslim countries safe safely.
Judaism's dying rising Messiah. We're
going to talk about that in this
session. Isaac, Abraham's resurrected
son.
Isaac's death and resurrection. Isaac's
binding and the third day resurrection.
Judaism on the atoning death of the
righteous. Can human death atone for
sins? There you go.
All of these I finished within the last
2 days.
See it? You can also find it here on the
blog.
Pray God bless Isaac that he'll preserve
him to preserve that blog and not turn
against me or delete it.
But in the meantime, save the the
articles.
All right? The high priest atoning
death. Judaism agrees the righteous save
the world.
The atoning blood
of Isaac.
Judas's dying and rising Messiah. Isaac,
Abraham's resurrected son. Isaac's death
and resurrection. You'll be shocked when
we get into the series.
Stuff I've known for a while, but I put
it in the back burner.
But thank the Lord I was watching a
recent
a recent discussion by Michael Brown.
Sadly,
I've met Michael Brown. Not sadly, I met
him. I like him as a person, but his
lust and fascination of Zionism disgust
me.
He's phenomenal at destroying rabbinic
Judaism's attack against the Messiahship
of Jesus, but being ethnically Jewish,
he will bend over backwards to defend
Israel and Zionism, and it disgust me.
All right? Isaac's binding and the third
day resurrection. So, because I watched
that lecture, it motivated me now to
find the references that I've been aware
of, cuz glory to Jesus, the internet is
here.
Use your neighbor's internet. Save
money, you cheapos, especially you cheap
Chaldeans, who don't give nothing for
ministry. That's why I'm going to be
struggling, all right? Cuz of you
cheapos, you millionaires. So, I went
back to be being an Assyrian. Gave you a
year, you cheapos.
You know, I go with the highest bidder.
Anyway,
all of this now is online. In the '90s,
early 2000s, we had to go buy the books
and
type out by hand. We'd have to retype.
Glory to God, I was able to find all the
sources. And another blessing,
Divine Mercy Apologetics,
has been such a blessing that I will
send him
a link to a book. Can you get it?
You know how much money he saved me in
the last year?
Cuz if I were to buy the books, yep,
and the library as well,
that I needed to produce these articles,
it would be costing me thousands of
dollars every year.
The man has saved me thousands by
sending me PDFs of the books.
Do you know that?
I'm talking about massive tomes that
cost maybe 100. Some of them, because
they don't
print as much, 200. Saved me tons of
money so I can do the work, copy and
paste for you.
I'm not trying to be here. I'm just
saying, I have this fire in me to make
the citations available on websites.
You can access them for free so you can
use them, destroy rabbinic Judaism,
destroy Zionism, destroy Islam, destroy
destroy them all so that everyone gets
saved.
And you bring them to Jesus.
Okay?
That's my desire for all of you.
That you'll have all the references.
And you know they're accurate because I
am very meticulous in making sure I
quote accurately.
So, no one can tell you you misquote.
And they're there and you will destroy
the lies
and bury these false religions.
But you need to study them, understand
them, read them, learn them, share them,
and pass them on. You need to do your
part.
Right?
So this is all the posts.
Judaism on the atoning death of the
righteous.
I think that the Yeah, that's the one,
right?
Isaac's binding and the third-day
resurrection. It's all there. So we're
going to finish old series, start new
ones. If you are praying for my health,
holiness, purity, safety,
and my daughters, and pray for
provision.
We're getting hit. People are panicking.
Remember, the first day of every month,
PayPal Patreon pays out. Pray I didn't
lose any support, that I have the same
amount of support I had last month, for
the glory of the triune God.